sechs wochen später rüdiger und steffi
befinden sich beide in therapie mein
gott ihr wisst nicht wie sehr ich auf
diesen satz gewartet habe heute ist es
der vierte oktober 2018 und ich habe
heute geburtstag ich bin heute zarte 23
jahre alt geworden aber wenn trotzdem
ihren machen video für euch und zwar gab
es eine sache in den letzten tagen der
ich einfach nicht entkommen konnte und
das war euer wunsch dass ich auf die
transformation reagiere wäre somit wie
bei dieser 40 jahre alte mann der sich
als kleines mädchen verkleidet und
scheinbar hatte den weg der besserung
befunden und will wieder zurück zu einem
normalen man menschen werden ich habe da
meine zweifel aber ich habe diese videos
zu schauen ist für mich so als würde
jemand zwei drei meter neben mir mit
kreide über eine tafel rutschen und das
macht dieses ewige gequatsche und grille
ungefähr dieses level an wohlgefühlt und
wieder aus
[Musik]
die gehen nicht zustande kommt nicht
immer so das geht zu weit dieses rum
geschreie und als 40 jähriger mann eine
piepsstimme wie ein vierjähriges mädchen
zwar das ist okay kein problem aber
diesen roten plastikstuhl mit dem fuss
leicht berühren möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen ist gute gehen zu
tante
hier hätte steffi die gelegenheit gehabt
rüdiger darin zu bestärken keine mädchen
klamotten mehr zu tragen diese chance
hat sie verpasst ohne seine mutter das
kleine rote sind wir jetzt ist klar am
anfang dieses video hat er endlich
halbwegs normale klamotten für ein mann
in seinem alter an und seine mutter
kommt rein und wundert sich der wahnsinn
ist bei den mittlerweile so zum alltag
geworden dass es seltsam ist wenn man
als erwachsener mann keine prinzessinnen
kleider anhat zur mittagszeit cosima
zitieren plan durch die 51-jährige will
unbedingt dass sich rüdiger endlich wie
ein mann verhält
villiger siehst du aus toll das ist
bombig steffi meine beste freundin habe
ich ja schon viel viel erzählt und ja
das ist er ruhiger und editor hallo liga
fuß nach hause
der mann ist kein kind mehr
was ist das für ein green [ __ ] jetzt
kommen noch einer dazu alles klar jeder
restaurantbesitzer darf gegenüber seinen
gästen ein hausverbot aus was ist das
denn wieder
also leute die haben wir bei hilfen
würden den beiden experten dann werden
diese frau wieso wahrscheinlich eine
psychologin sein soll oder so tut als
wäre eine psychologin wir haben denen
hier also jemand der sich mit
rechtlichen gelegenheiten auskennt und
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen eine
psychologin ist bei diesen videoinhalten
absolut benötigt eigentlich erreicht
eine nicht eigentlich müsste man zehn
psychotherapeuten für jede folge
einsetzen einfach um die menge an
geistiger beschädigung die in so eine
video angerichtet wird irgendwie wieder
herzustellen aber er habe auch komplett
fehler platz die schreien einfach gerade
zwei minuten durcheinander
und dann erzählt er immer irgendwas über
warehouse wurde verteilen davon wenn ich
du kannst dir nichts vernünftiges von
hausverbot erzählen der wissen die in
der fucking irrenanstalt kurz darauf
berufen oder es gibt ja irgendwann
versucht eine mega aufgebrezelte frau
mit einem mann zu verkuppeln der seit
vermutlich jahren denkt essen
vierjähriges mädchen was könnte da
schief gehen
jetzt wird sie von vorne am altar ein
bisschen ruhig wir sehen hier ein
erwachsener mann der sich ein bisschen
sondern ein bisschen komisch verhält
[Gelächter]
bisschen ist untertrieben
[Musik]
jetzt gibt arbeitet er rasiert großstadt
your life sechs wochen später rüdiger
und steffi befinden sich beide in
therapie oh mein gott ihr wisst nicht
wie sehr ich auf diesen satz gewartet
habe rüdiger und steffi befinden sich
beide in therapie rüdiger hat
mittlerweile verstanden dass er kein
kleines mädchen ist und steffi versucht
ihn wie einen 35 jährigen mann zu
behandeln
dort war es dass endlich leute ist der
schrecken endlich vorbei ist auch auf
dem spielplatz vielleicht schlimm damals
gibt dass der vater genauso großes weg
leute das ist vorbei
[Musik]